[Music]
this was a funeral and far more
its congregation voiced our country's
concern at what had brought them here
Kamala Harris
the vice president grieved with the
mother of Tyree Nichols and spoke for a
government
son and their brother
through an act of violence
at the hands and the feet
of people who had been charged with
keeping them safe
we were shown fresh pictures of Tyree
Nichols he wasn't the only victim of
police violence represented here at his
funeral I know the family of George
Floyd is here stand up relatives of
others who died previously traveled to
Memphis come on it was the past and
present standing side by side for change
in future
we have to fight for justice
we cannot continue to let these people
brutalize our kids
in the wake of the video release of
Tyree Nichols fatal beating the Memphis
fire department has announced that three
employees have been sacked for failing
to assist him
this after the firing of the five police
officers facing charges of second-degree
murder
they were addressed directly at his
funeral here in the city that saw the
assassination of Martin Luther King the
Civil Rights leader who had a dream
in the city
with a dream
laid down and shed his blood
you have the unmitigated gall
to beat your brother
chase him down and beat them some more
and she laid her son to rest the mother
of Tyree Nichols talked politics
urging the adoption of the so-called
George Floyd Bill to limit police
immunity it was a mother's plea to a
nation's politicians we need to get that
bill passed amen because if we don't
know that blood the next child that dies
that blood is going to be on their hands
yeah James Matthews Sky News Washington
[Applause]